want to give you a little history on  homelessness please 19 and 10  hitler decided to live on the streets  for a while  so for two years hitler lived on the  streets and practiced his oratory and  his body language and how to connect  with faces and then went on to a leader  life that got him in the history book so  a lot of these people it's not a dead  end they can come out of this these  homeless camps and have a productive  life  or in hitler's case a very unproductive  life  um  guys i i get he's not saying you know it  was delightful hitler was homeless and  then he came out and he was able to kill  six million jews i get that he's not  saying that  but why do you have to point to hitler  and also if hitler chose to be homeless  in order to practice his oratory skills  and uh and body language most homeless  people are not trying to build public  speaking uh skills by by being homeless